the father of a little girl allegedly
kidnapped and killed by a package
delivery driver is now suing the suspect
and FedEx Athena strand's dad says FedEx
as well as the contracting company that
hired Tanner Lynn Horner were negligent
and failed to supervise Horner Horner
told police that he was delivering a
package to strand's home when he
accidentally reversed the truck into the
seven-year-old Horner says even though
he wasn't she wasn't seriously injured
he panicked and put Athena in his truck
and eventually strangled her the
complaint alleges that FedEx and the
Contracting Company failed to
investigate Horner's criminal history
mental health history and prior
employment Jacob strand's lawsuit is
seeking more than one million dollars in
Damages along with a jury trial Terry
you're a you were a Civil Trial attorney
what do you think of the case is it
FedEx at fault here oh yeah I definitely
think they may be at fault here anytime
you have an employee a subcontractor or
even an independent contractor if
they're involved in an incident like
this the victim or the victim's family
they can claim they negligent hiring
negligent training or negligent
supervision and that's because every
employer has a duty to ensure a safe
environment for its employees and even
its customers so of course the incident
has to occur during the scope and course
of the employment if it's outside of
that then obviously there's no
responsibility as far as the employer is
concerned but to prove the case you have
to say that the individual was driving a
company vehicle or delivering a package
at the time and that does seem to be the
case here and as you said based on that
complaint they're alleging that both
FedEx and the subcontractor they fail to
investigate him and if he had a
background that was violent then he
should not have been hired Brian what do
you think you think the Strand family
has a strong chance of winning their
suit I want them to win but I don't
think it's going to be that easy Texas
has very strong third party liability
where they're not liable for the overt
criminal acts of a third party now if he
had just hit Athena and then walked off
they might have been liable for that but
they're not liable for that over
criminal act of kidnapping and then
killing her so that's going to be
difficult for them and even if they do
Sue I think FedEx is going to point the
finger at the subcontractor Big Top Spin
Inc and try to get the money out of them
I think FedEx may be able to dodge and
weave away from liability but at the end
of the day I do think Athena strand's
Family will win because you don't want
to be seen as a large company who then
ends up indirectly even killing this
young girl and then dodging any kind of
accountability yeah you might be right I
don't know if they're going to win or
not but I tell you I'm not surprised
that they brought this lawsuit not at
all not shocked by that it's completely
understandable well we do have several
updates on cases that we've been
following closely for you first the
parents charged with involuntary
manslaughter after their son shot up a
school are facing quite an uphill battle
when it comes to getting Bond Jennifer
and James crumbly are the parents of the
Oxford school shooter who killed four
students last year now he pleaded guilty
the parents are trying to get Bond and
provided the name of a person that they
could stay with if they were released
but the court did a background check and
found that that person has quite a
checkered past so right now an appeals
court is set to determine if the couple
can get bail or not the prosecution says
the crumblies knew their son had mental
health issues but not only ignored them
but bought a gun the oldest daughter of
the late basketball star Kobe Bryant has
been granted a restraining order Natalia
Bryant testified about Dwayne Kemp in
court on Wednesday she already had a
temporary order against him but now that
protective order will last at least
three years and Camp has to surrender
any weapons that he owns Brian says Kemp
started contact her when she was 17 and
believes the two are in a relationship
even though Brian has never met him
in just a few short weeks Todd and Julie
Chrisley will have to report to federal
prison the reality star couple known for
the show Chrisley Knows Best will serve
their sentences for fraud at separate
prisons in Florida a federal judge
sentenced Todd Chrisley to 12 years in
prison and his wife Julie to seven years
the couple were found guilty of
conspiring to defraud Banks and the IRS
out of millions of dollars the two are
appealing their convictions while jurors
in the Harvey Weinstein trial will soon
enter their ninth day of deliberation
does the long discussion hint at which
way the jury is leaning
analyze the situation when we come back
[Music]
welcome back everybody it's been two
weeks since jurors started deliberating
in the sexual assault trial of Harvey
Weinstein and still no verdict out of
Los Angeles the disgraced Hollywood
Mogul sits behind bars as he faces a
possible life sentence on seven sexual
assault charges the charges stemmed from
four different women all of whom took
the stand for the prosecution Weinstein
himself didn't testify in his own
defense but his team says that the
accuser's stories are fabricated it
raised suspicion that the jury didn't
ask any questions during the first part
of deliberations but it turns out that
they were hidden from the public you see
judge Lisa Lynch has been taking jury
questions over the phone in closed court
and journalists at the courthouse
weren't too happy according to courtman
it's the first question on December 6
asked for a read back of testimony
another question asked on December 9th
wasn't disclosed the jury is going to
return on Monday to continue
deliberations and hear more readbacks of
testimony Brian if the judge doesn't
show the journalists the notes does that
mean that we're never going to know what
the jury asked never is probably a
strong word to use you're probably just
not going to hear it until the case is
done with and maybe they're on appeal of
course the court record is a part of the
public distribution of information and
what happens with those notes just like
evidence just like video just like
testimony it gets added to the court
record and the court files so there
could be a foil request they can be
um maybe just reporters who asked to see
the court file and have it copied
depending on how the clerk is feeling
that day I don't think the answer is
never but I just think it's not going to
happen at a time that we want it and
it's not going to happen before we learn
about the verdict or once they reach
your verdict there's a mistrial they
might just decide to do interviews maybe
they'll do an interview with long crime
and tell us what was happening behind
the scenes but Terry before we get to
that the jury they're still deliberating
too late to reach a plea deal
Jesse it is never ever too late to plea
deal you know 90 of the cases are pled
out and frankly you can make a deal at
arraignment when you first come to court
or you can make a deal anytime before
the verdict and the judge will have to
accept that you know you can ask the
prosecution or the prosecution can
approach you you talk to the judge and
the judge will decide whether or not
this is a deal that he thinks is good
and in the interest of the public and
you know they can in fact even reach a
deal after the verdict if in fact the
defendant appeals the prosecution may
want to look at that and take their
chances to determine whether or not this
is a merit or Merit list appeal and if
they think that there's some Merit to
the appeal they can even then reach some
sort of agreement and all of this is
because you know there's a backlog in
cases and covid-19 did not help so it is
in the best interest of everybody the
judge the prosecution the defendant if
in fact they can reach something that's
reasonable something that's good for the
public then they'll try to do that and
looking at Harvey Wednesday I can't tell
all this time if it benefits him or not
I think if the jury came back in 10
minutes it probably wouldn't have been
good for him this not so sure we don't
know what's happening Brian Terry thanks
so much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily we
will see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]